this episode of real engineering was
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 16,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill 2017 was the safest
year in aviation history with zero
deaths from commercial passenger jets
and just 44 onboard fatalities
attributed to the aviation industry as a
whole when military and cargo flights
are factored in despite ever-increasing
demand for flights and the numbers of
passengers flying soaring to 4 billion
in 2017 the number of crashes has
declined dramatically over the decades
figuring out why crashes have reduced so
dramatically we first have to ask
ourselves why do crashes happen in the
first place although the number of
crashes have continually fallen the
statistical cause of crashes has
remained fairly stable with pilot error
mechanical failure severe weather and
sabotage being the consistent highest
cause of fatalities let's dive deeper
into the history of aviation to see how
the airline industry has adapted to
become safer over the past century going
right back to the early decades of the
aviation industry an era dominated by
male planes and Barnstormers flying was
a hugely risky endeavor planes were
cheap and operators valued timely
delivery over pilot safety not that the
competitive daredevil pilots needed much
pushing plane technology was in its
infancy and crashes were frequent an
airmail pilot during this period had a 1
in 4 chance in meeting their end at the
controls of their aircraft these cowboy
days of flight were short-lived with the
arrival of increasingly expensive planes
a burgeoning commercial passenger
industry and with the formation of the
first pilots union in 1931 operators
were forced to think about reliability
not only for the safety of their
passengers and pilots but to protect
their financial interests profit was
threatened even further after a landmark
case in 1936 when the widow of a fallen
pilot Joe Livermore successfully sued
Northwest Airlines for pressuring her
husband into flying in dangerous
conditions but overzealous employers
could not be blamed for all crashes even
in the case of Joe Livermore Livermore
was an older pilot which in these days
meant you were in your 30s familiar with
the navigation method of contact flying
using visual references on the ground to
Navi
which required flying below the clouds
where turbulence and terrain post a much
higher risk Livermore's locky 10 was
equipped with instruments that allowed
him to navigate above the clouds using
electronic Airways and he was expected
to use it the system used radio beacons
that guided the pilots between stations
along the intended route each beacon
would transmit Morse code in alternating
90-degree quadrants the so if you were
flying in quadrant a you would only be
able to hear the Morse code for that
quadrant in the next quadrant the n
quadrant you would hear the mirror-image
code and when flying between the two the
signals joined to form a steady tone
which designated the airway thus each
beacon was capable of producing four
Airways this system relied completely on
the pilots ability to decipher the
signal and Static could interfere with
the reception not only this but pilots
had no way of knowing if they were
heading towards the station or away from
it getting lost with a plane that has
limited fuel is obviously not ideal and
passing through cloud cover without
certainty of the terrain below was a
harrowing experience and it wasn't
unheard of for phantom signals from
distant stations skipping through the
atmosphere luring pilots to their deaths
either while this method of flying is
vastly safer than flying in the lower
atmosphere to avoid pilot error
pilots needed reliable foolproof
equipment that will not lead them astray
radio navigation is still in use today
but has improved dramatically computers
now interpret the radio signal and
provide a readout on instrumentation
such as the automatic direction finder
the oldest radio navigation instruments
still in use which points the pilot in
the direction of the tuned station and
autopilot systems are capable of
tracking a selected route using this
method
yet even with dramatic improvements
catastrophic incidents were still
possible due to pilot error take Korean
Airlines flight 0:07
where the pilots incorrectly programmed
the autopilot system causing the plane
to track a straight bearing over Russian
airspace where it was shot down this
event led to further improvements in
autopilot interfaces to reduce the
chances of pilot error and was the
primary driver for the Ronald Reagan
administration opening global
positioning satellite access to the
world providing even more redundancy to
the tools pilots rely upon to safely
complete their job the importance of
reliable instrumentation cannot be
overstated navigation areas are now a
thing of the past but they are not the
only instrumentation that a pilot relies
upon a faulty sensor is like pitot tubes
which are these tubes that you can see
on the outside of the plane that measure
airspeed can be attributed to several
crashes over the past decade flying a
plane without reliable speed data is
incredibly difficult if not near
impossible the 2009 crash of Air France
flight 447 which killed 228 people is a
perfect example of this the pitot tubes
work simply by measuring the pressure
caused by the force of moving air
attempting to enter the tube the
the plane travels the higher the
pressure allowing the pitot tube to
measure the airspeed very accurately the
pitot tubes of flight 447 failed as it
was flying through the Intertropical
Convergence zone an area prone to tundra
storms here the pitot tube began to fill
with ice blocking the passage of air to
the sensor and thus dropping the air
pressure the aircraft registered a
malfunction and turned off the autopilot
giving manual control over to a panicked
crew who had no visual horizon in the
pitch-black of a storm and proceeded to
enter the plane into a stall resulting
in a deadly crash into the Atlantic
Ocean it took two years to find the
black box and discovered the exact cause
of the crash pitot tubes are equipped
with drainage holes and heating elements
to prevent this kind of problem but this
particular model became overwhelmed with
ice before it could be cleared after
this crash Airbus replaced these flawed
pitot tubes and pilots were warned of
the problem which brings us to our next
life-saving measure the humble checklist
just three years after this fatal crash
a very similar problem struck a reiner
flight on approach to riga airport
through moderate snowfall when the pitot
tube heater failed when speed
measurements became erratic and the
autopilot switched itself off the pilots
were quick to level off flight at 4,000
feet and begin to work their checklist
checking each pitot tube output and
comparing it with measurements from
alternative sensors like the inertial
reference system to figure out which
sensor was faulty allowing them to find
a reliable readout on the captain
sensors and safely land the plane the
history of aircraft safety is defined by
trial and error learning accidents by
their very nature are caused by
unpredicted circumstances and even our
understanding of weather has improved
through our obsession with flight take
the discovery of the microburst weather
phenomenon that mysteriously downed
multiple planes like Delta flight 191
microburst are characterized by a column
of rapidly descending air that spreads
out horizontally as it strikes the
ground microburst are perhaps the most
dangerous of all weather phenomenon that
threaten planes with strong erratic
winds imagine a plane flying into a
microburst
at first it will experience strong
turbulence and a perceived increase in
air speed as the plane encounters a
strong headwind tempting the pilot to
reduce power next the plane encounters
the incredibly strong down bursts of air
which could be enough to down the plane
own and as it passes through the
downward draft the air direction flips
suddenly to a tailwind resulting in a
sudden loss of lift which would be made
even worse if the pilot had indeed
reduced power when the headwind was
first encountered these effects combined
resulted in flight 191 hitting the
ground a mile short of the runway
killing 134 of the 163 on board and one
person on the ground when the downed
plane collided with hair this crash
along with several similar prior crashes
resulted in a seven-year investigation
by NASA and the FAA resulting in the
discovery of the microburst phenomenon
and the introduction of onboard wind
shear radar to detect them this
improvement may never have been possible
without the black box which gave
investigators vital data on the air
speeds flight 191 encountered helping
them piece together an incredibly
difficult puzzle the black box was
introduced in 1953 after a string of
crashes of the de Havilland comet which
fell foul of unforeseen stress
concentration in the corners of its
square windows and fatigue stress from
repeated pressurization cycles leading
to the introduction of round windows and
a better understanding of fatigue stress
but it also inspired Australian inventor
David Warren to provide a tool to help
air crash investigators solve their
mysteries it's a simple concept a
heavily protected box that can survive
fire water and impact it is perhaps the
most valuable tool at our disposal in
our quest to minimize the likelihood of
future crashes yet even now the
technology is not perfect crashes like
Malaysian Airlines mh370 remains a
mystery as the black box was never found
and it's likely policies will be changed
to have flight data continually streamed
in real-time to ground stations to
eliminate the need to locate the flight
recorder after a crash we could be here
all day detailing these learning
experiences but thus the core of waif
line became radically safer we are
continually learning and preventing
repeated mistakes systems have
continually improved to drastically
reduce the chances of human error the
largest contributor to crashes systems
like fly-by-wire have been developed
that prevent pilots from pushing the
plane beyond its capabilities
instruments that the pilots and air
traffic controls disposal have improved
and been computerized engines and flight
structures have become vastly more
reliable and our ability to predict and
avoid
adverse weather has improved and
navigation is now pinpoint accurate
thanks to GPS but these improvements
don't explain the radical difference in
safety between airlines and countries
operating in the same year the odds of
you dying on the top 39 safest airlines
is about one and twenty million reverse
that and take the bottom thirty-nine
airlines and your chance is one in two
million ten times the likelihood it's
not hard to differentiate between the
top airlines and the bottom airlines the
key difference being an airline's
ability to maintain older aircraft or
buy new ones
Iran exemplifies this problem with 94
airliner accidents in the past decade
resulting in 741 deaths much of this can
be blamed on sanctions placed on Iran
forcing them to rely an older unreliable
aircraft which have not benefited from
the lessons of the past the problem is
further compounded by a severe lack of
replacement parts preventing vital
maintenance work these problems are so
bad that airlines like Iran Osman which
just this year suffered a crash killing
all 65 passengers on board have been
banned from flying to Europe with
sanctions lifted around Airlines look
poised to buy a hundred 80 aircraft from
Airbus and Boeing to renew their aging
fleet updating our technology is our
greatest tool in improving aircraft
reliability and ensuring the safety of
our passengers learning is the greatest
tool humans possess which is why I am
always happy to work with Skillshare
Skillshare is home to thousands of
classes and graphic design animation web
development music photography video game
design and more recently one of my
incredibly stupid friends asked me to
shoot his wedding video and I told him
straight up I am no professional
videographer but I want to do my best
for an old friend so I started watching
this course and Skillshare for
inspiration and it's actually just a
really good introduction to videography
in general I'm doing this for a friend
but you could easily find a course here
to help you develop new marketable
skills these days you can teach yourself
pretty much any skill online and
Skillshare is a fantastic place to do it
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve you can dive in and start learning
how to do the work you love a premium
membership begins around $10 a month for
unlimited access to all courses for the
first 1,000 people to sign up with this
link will get their first two months for
just 99 cents so ask yourself right now
what skill have you been putting off
learning while project have you been
dreaming of completing but you aren't
sure if you have the skills to do it
why not start right now and sign up to
skill share using the link below you've
nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain as usual thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Twitter Facebook
and Instagram pages are below